you've located everything we need
it's got to be building something he's
taking whatever he wants killing anybody
that gets in the way
she's stealing pieces of tech but God
knows you're right we have to figure out
ways building right now we can keep them
on the true path
Clifford - the
we can see everyone
on this Tuesday at 8/7 central on the CW
hey everybody its charlie we got some
new flash to breakdown accelerated man
is back
we're going back to mercury labs and we
got some more clues for what's going on
with coffee shop girl because of this
notepad here this may look familiar
because it's the exact same one the
coffee shop girl is scribbling those
Speed Force symbols in so if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the DC videos
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
that is just be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video you may have also
noticed the big thing - this was a big
question on my last flash video about
killer frost abilities because of the
way the thinker absorbed the power
swapping meta there was a question about
what happened to her powers after he
took them from her because people were
like wait a minute he only swaps DNA
like what did he do with those powers
but here you see him using a giant blast
of frost so it's pretty clear that he's
using her powers himself which I think
you know might be a small continuity
error maybe they'll explain it during
the episode because it seems like a big
surprise like he just takes them down
while they're inside mercury labs trying
to stop him the other very obvious thing
is the [ __ ] is back to help them out
because she cares part of this big fight
that's probably where we see accelerated
man so we might travel to earth 19 to
see him but I have a feeling that they
didn't put him in the trailer because he
might just not be a huge part of the
episode tracked her down on earth two
breaches taken care of
thank you risky move coming to an earth
where interdimensional travel is
punishable by death especially when I'm
the one who's supposed to hold that law
I need to talk to you
I don't do long-distance relationships
don't get me wrong this is something I'd
love to talk about in more detail
especially if this is your only
hesitation many thanks to the director
for posting these behind the scenes
pictures because ever since the end of
season 3 one of the biggest questions
that I've gotten about old versions of
the flash coming back this is when is
accelerated man coming back because one
he has one of the coolest costumes so
it's just a really cool pitch you have
the old timey looking flash kind of like
a Jay Garrick spent only even more
old-timey but I think they were just
saving him for a special episode that
involved earth 19 heavily and now you
have that with this Cisco plot like come
take my place join the breachers because
Danny Trejo wants to go hang out with
some dragons on the dragon planet but if
you're wondering I don't think that
Danny Trejo is anywhere in here I think
it's just [ __ ] from the two of them but
I imagine that she just been doing her
normal thing so cisco has that
heart-to-heart with her where he
explains what her father told him they
do invoke some Tina McGee here like you
see this machine it just says McGee on
it so that's why I think that they're in
mercury labs here I don't know when
they're gonna bring her back maybe she
appears briefly during the episode
there's so much that they don't put in
these trailers because I think that
they're trying to market to younger
people and they're like well you know
younger people they don't care about
these older flash characters which is
totally false more Jay Garrick more Tina
McGee more people from the classic flash
TV show always bring back Mark Hamill
side benefit of this next week's episode
is that we actually probably have a good
idea of what the Enlightenment device
really does by the end of it but also
you have this moment here where Marley's
is like hey maybe we uh maybe we don't
kill them all and the thinker is just
completely off his rocker the more
powers he absorbs the less he's able to
identify with other humans the closer he
gets to becoming a living god on earth
so it just sounds like his character has
this slow descent arc where he's like
you know what maybe everybody does not
deserve to be enlightened well Marley's
is trying to remind him of there
original idea like way back in episode 7
when you had the flashbacks to when
there at the University where he's like
you know what we can actually make
things better we can make the human race
better it wasn't originally an evil idea
it was just an idea to make the world a
better place so coffee shop girl the
title of the episode is therefore she is
which is a reference to DeVos wife
because the thinker origin story episode
episode 7 was there for I am so this is
a sort of the other side of that
equation so it sounds like she drives
most of the episode we see her wearing
this little bandana this is the
thinker's wife Marlies reading this
notebook with the scribblings in it in
that brain drawing so it looks like
maybe one of her old drawings or maybe
it used to belong to davao but the
reason why i think this is the exact
same notepad the coffee shop girl is
scribbling in is is because it has this
little fold-over flap so you look at
coffee shop girl back during episode 11
where she opens her notebook and you can
see a little flap here on the side just
like the one that Marley's is holding
here in the notepad itself looks of
similar size the paper looks kind of the
same so the question is then what does
she have to do with the thinker's family
because there's been a lot of people
like a growing contingent of people I've
seen in the comments that are like what
if copy shop girl is Marley's in Davos
daughter the way she talked to Cisco and
elongated man made it sound like she was
from very far in the future like not
just a little ways in the future but a
long time because the Oregon Trail shirt
was meant to be quaint like oh yeah it's
retro I'm gonna have to wait to see the
episode if we get a coffee shop girl
scene and see if that gives any more
credence to that Marley's coffee shop
girl theory but the next episode episode
21 is titled Harry in the Harrisons and
it's sort of a spin on the Council of
wells episode that they used to do
because the old council is supposed to
boot him out because he's not as smart
as he used to be like they want the
smartest person but Cisco introduces him
to another council of Wells that they
call the Harrisons which maybe is more
accepting of him but there's no
reference to coffee shop girl or
speedforce symbols in the description
for episode 21 so it does sound like
they're gonna stretch this coffee shop
girl thing
to the very end of the season but just
be prepared based on new evidence in
next week's episode to change your
coffee shop girl theory but I have a
feeling that Marley's looking at that
notebook isn't a coincidence and that
they'll somehow reference the notebook
the coffee shop girl was scribbling in
but I almost forgot the other thing too
is that some of these speedforce symbols
that the scribbling in the notebook were
actually on des Vosges note board way
back during episode 7 before his mind
started to degenerate and things got
really crazy so just more evidence tying
coffee shop girl to DeVoe and Marley's I
will go on record as saying that I'll be
fine with whatever they do with coffee
shop girl is long is whatever twists
they're trying to pull off feels justify
like as long as they've earned it I'll
be ok with it
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner mad monkey please private message
me so I can get your contact details
there'll be a new round when I post new
DC later this week there was new Aquaman
footage at CinemaCon but because the
visual effects aren't done I don't think
that they're gonna drop it till Comic
Con this summer but just be prepared
there been a bunch of trailers dropping
so I might do a separate video about
that between all the infinity war stuff
that's happening so obviously a whole
bunch of infinity war posting in the
next couple of days so brace yourself
but click here for my no spoiler
infinity war review and click here for
my flash episode video from this week
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight